Speaker 1: Last night, Ron DeSantis, the Republican
governor of Florida, was brutalized by challenger
Charlie Crist to the point where at one, at
multiple moments during the debate, DeSantis
appeared to be malfunctioning.
His brain looked like it was malfunctioning.
He didn't know what to say and in some cases
didn't say anything.
This is wild.
Charlie Crist is almost certainly going to
lose to Ron DeSantis now losing by about ten
points in Florida.
But this was one of the best performances
by Charlie Crist of any 2022 candidate.
Let's get right into it now.
By the way, before as we jump in.
Even many of the topics.
We're topics that it's sort of a joke that
they were even being discussed critical race
theory.
Talking about the fact that trans people exist,
the the very existence of these issues rather
than substantive issues of actual relevance.
It already shows the degree to which the right
has dominated the framing and has shifted
the Overton Window to the absurd.
But let's put that aside for a second.
Ron DeSantis doesn't like the approach that
some schools are taking because he says it
teaches that the U.S. was built on stolen
land.
Wait a second, wasn't it?
Speaker 2: It actually, if you look around
the country, they do have programs, unfortunately,
where they will take a student look at their
race.
Okay.
You're white.
You're an oppressor.
If you're black, you're oppressed.
And think about what that does to a six or
seven year old kid.
That's wrong.
You're saying that you have people that are
teaching and actually his running mate has
said this in the past, that teaching the United
States was built on stolen land.
That is inappropriate for not true.
Speaker 3: And I'm happy.
Can you.
Speaker 1: Imagine?
Now it's.
It's not unique.
Like, it's.
We live in the U.S.
So a lot of history that's taught to kids
is U.S. history.
You know, in other countries, interestingly
enough, kids are taught more global history.
But okay, put that aside for a second.
It's the U.S.
So kids are taught U.S. history.
It's not unique that the U.S. now exists on
what we would accurately call stolen land.
I mean, countries in 2022 are on land that
was stolen, won by war, annexed, purchased
or created by international treaty.
It's not really a special thing.
It's not unique to the United States, the
Roman Empire, the Zulu empire, the Mongol
empire.
You look at the history of how Japan came
to be, what it is.
It's all a combination of these few mechanisms.
It's not special.
It's not a unique pejorative to teach the
reality these people live in a fantasy world.
Now, what became a very big issue during yesterday's
debate and Charlie Crist handled it very well.
Charlie Crist pointed out multiple times,
DeSantis is angling to run for president.
Will he commit to actually serving out his
four year gubernatorial term?
And each time DeSantis was more and more flustered
by it.
Very, very interesting.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Ron, you talk about Joe Biden a
lot.
I understand you think you're going to be
running against him.
I can see how you might get confused.
But you're running for governor.
You're running for governor.
And I have a question for you.
Why don't you look in the eyes of the people
of the state of Florida and say to them, if
you're reelected, you will serve a full four
year term as governor, yes or no?
Yes or no.
Speaker 1: This is the point at which it looks
like this.
This is brain is malfunctioning.
Speaker 2: Will you serve a full four year
term if you're reelected governor of Florida?
It's not a tough question.
It's a fair question.
He won't tell you.
Speaker 4: We did not agree on the candidates
asking each other.
My.
Governor, it's your turn.
Speaker 2: Well, listen, I know that Charlie
is interested in talking about 2024 and Joe
Biden, but I just want to make things very,
very clear.
The only worn out old donkey I'm looking to
put out to pasture is Charlie Crist.
Speaker 1: So there, of course, Crist, about
20 something years older than Ron DeSantis
and Ron DeSantis going in that direction.
But this really didn't get any better.
It continued.
And it was it was quite ugly.
And telling about Ron DeSantis.
Speaker 3: Only.
Speaker 2: Worn out old donkey I'm looking
to put out to pasture is Charlie Crist.
Yeah.
Well, Ron, we know you love to bully people
and the little name calling you just exchanged.
I can take it, but you shouldn't do it when
children are standing behind you at a press
conference when they're wearing a mask.
True.
Speaker 1: But apparently that Crist did very,
very well in this debate.
I don't know that it will actually be enough
to make a difference, but it was quite a scene.
Speaker 2: Because you like having it as an
issue for political scoring in points that
you want to have for a future campaign.
And let me remind our viewers, he wouldn't
even answer you if he would stay for years
if you reelect him as your governor.
You're running for governor.
You're asking them to vote for you for governor.
At a minimum, you ought to be able to tell
them if you get reelected, you'll serve as
governor.
Ron.
Governor.
So we had the border that was in much better
shape in January of 2021.
Speaker 1: And the audience really noticing
he does not want to answer that question because
he obviously is getting set up to run for
president.
Then the topic of abortion came up.
Ron DeSantis said he's proud of the 15 week
abortion ban that Florida passed and he wrongly
claims that at 15 weeks, babies are fully
formed.
Speaker 2: I'm proud of the 15 weeks that
we did.
I know Charlie Crist opposes that, even though
the baby is fully formed, has a heartbeat,
can feel pain and can suck their thumb.
He also supports sex selective abortions.
Speaker 1: That was someone screaming Liar.
Speaker 2: Is used to discriminate against
little girls.
He supports dismemberment abortions where
they literally will tear the baby limb from
limb.
And he supports taxpayer funding of abortion
all the way up until the moment of birth.
And that is.
Speaker 1: Right.
Yeah.
Now, understand that there is debate over
what fully formed means.
Certainly there is no viability at 15 weeks.
But the truth is that it's actually irrelevant
to the debate.
And what I mean by that is the following.
Do you think for a second, if it was proven
to the extent that it could be proven that
a fetus is not fully formed by any definition
at 15 weeks?
Do you think people like DeSantis would all
of a sudden go, Oh, you know what?
Now that we've determined the fetus isn't
fully formed at 15 weeks, I'm okay with abortion.
No, of course not.
That's the trick.
That it doesn't actually matter to them.
They are just coming up with whatever they
can say to justify increasingly draconian
abortion restrictions.
The crowd wasn't loving it.
At another moment, the topic of business came
up.
Charlie Crist doing an excellent job of flipping
around, who is pro-business on DeSantis, who
claims to be a very pro-business Republican.
Crist was very well prepared.
Speaker 2: I'm pro-business.
I want to make sure we keep our businesses
open.
I'm not the governor who attacked Walt Disney
World because they deign to express their
political.
I'm not the governor who attacked the cruise
industry because I just wanted to make sure
that their customers weren't sick before they
got on the boat.
That's you.
You're the most anti-business governor I've
ever seen.
Speaker 1: DeSantis was increasingly annoyed,
and interestingly, he he had this attitude
sort of similar actually to Marco Rubio in
his debate last week, that even having to
be there is sort of beneath him.
He seemed resentful that he even had to debate
the topic of the Martha's Vineyard flights
came up.
Remember this stunt we're in?
Marco, I'm sorry, not Marco Rubio.
Ron DeSantis paid to fly migrants from Texas
to Martha's Vineyard.
And again, Crist was very well prepared.
Speaker 4: State Congressman.
Speaker 2: I thought what the governor did
was a horrible political stunt.
You know, we have an immigration problem.
We have a problem at the border.
We need to secure the border.
I agree with all of that.
But it doesn't mean that you use Florida taxpayers
dollars to charter two jets.
Go to Texas.
Lie to people to get them on to planes.
Fly them up to the northern part of our country.
And and one of them's a one year old baby.
Another is a pregnant woman.
You're willing to use people like that?
In this case, they were Hispanics, Venezuelan
in particular, and have them as props for
your political gain.
That's not the way to change policy.
You can change policy and do what's right
to secure the border by having comprehensive
immigration reform.
That's what I voted for in Congress when you
were in Congress.
You wouldn't do it because you want to keep
this issue alive.
You want to have it as a wedge issue, and
you want to pull political stunts like you
did with the taxpayers dollars of the people
of Florida.
That's not what it's for.
That's not what you should have done.
It isn't funny.
It's not right.
And you were inhumane and how you treated
these people.
Speaker 1: And DeSantis really didn't have
any substantive rebuttal.
It was just sort of like, well, you know,
we have a real problem and the Crist Biden
border crisis and blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
Last thing here, when Ron DeSantis tried to
close out the debate, claiming he led the
pandemic response based on facts, someone
very succinctly in the audience just yells
out Liar.
Which is, of course, an accurate criticism.
Speaker 2: When a once in a century pandemic
hit.
I lead based on facts, not based on.
Speaker 1: Right.
So a disastrous debate for Ron DeSantis.
But I hate to tell you, it probably will not
make a difference.
If you live in Florida, you should vote.
There's no doubt about it.
It is right now a ten point deficit, a ten
point deficit for Charlie Crist.
Charlie Crist would be a fine governor for
Florida.
Ron DeSantis is a disaster.
He is using this to set up his presidential
run if it's convenient, if it ends up going
that way, without a doubt.
Really good debate for Charlie Crist.
DeSantis fumbling and looking malfunctioning,
almost Trump like glitches.
But DeSantis, sadly, will probably win.
But maybe not.
Let's all vote.
Remember that we have a YouTube channel approaching
2 million subscribers.
I found out an incredible piece of data last
week.
My colleague John told me this Even though
we had four and a half million different people
watch videos on our YouTube channel last month.
Only about one and a half million are subscribed.
There are 3 million viewers on YouTube who
watch our clips but aren't subscribed.
Make sure you hit that subscribe button because
it is so important for the algorithm and for
signaling to YouTube that our content is engaging
enough for people to want to subscribe.
There are 3 million of you out there and I
am speaking to you today.
Make sure to join the ranks of our YouTube
subscribers.
It's free.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this.